howdy at the beginning of this century
scientist sequences three billion
nucleotides making carbs a human genome
a breakthrough that change the landscape
of modern biology and initiated the era
of personalized medicine but what does
it mean to sequence a genome to
illustrate how biologists sequence
genomes we want to give you a brain
teaser imagine that we collect a hundred
copies of the June 27 2000 edition of
the New York Times now imagine that we
put all these newspapers on a stack of
dynamite so after we blow up all the
newspapers into a crazy cloud of
confetti we want to give you a challenge
how is it that we would use all these
scraps of newspaper that are just lying
around to figure out what the news was
on June 27 2000 you are probably
wondering chords this crazy newspaper
problem has to do with these genome
sequences biologists cannot simply read
your genome from beginning to end in the
ways that you would read a book what
biologists can do is read very short
pieces of DNA but they do not know where
in the genome these pieces belong so the
blast many of copies of your genome into
millions of pieces and read each piece
afterwards it is a job of a computer
scientist to assemble the resulting
overlapping fragments of DNA into your
genome this is just like the newspaper
problems that Phillip described and it
is the largest puzzle that humans have
ever tried to assemble how is it that we
can put together a genome from millions
of short fragments of DNA to answer this
question we're gonna need to travel back
in time three centuries when the
residents of the city of königsberg had
a question is it possible to start
anywhere in this city walk across each
of its seven bridges exactly once and
then return back to where you started
you are probably wondering what these
bridges of königsberg problem has to do
with
assembling genomes in this class we will
see the genome assembly can be viewed as
working through a giant city of these
millions of bridges and visiting each
bridge exactly once after we learn how
to assemble genomes will also consider
deciphering sequences of antibiotics
which are many proteins or short strings
of amino acids surprisingly sequencing a
million nucleotide long bacterial genome
is much easier today than sequencing
just a short ten to fifteen amino acid
long antibiotic like daptomycin which is
used to treat life-threatening
infections as with genome sequencing
biologists sequence an antibiotic by
first blasting many of its copies into
tiny little pieces
however unlike with genome sequencing
they are not able to read the amino
acids that make up each of these pieces
instead biologists need to weigh them
using an expensive molecular scale
called a mass spectrometer but how in
the world can we sequence an antibiotic
if all we know are the masses of its
fragments we hope that you'll join us on
this wild trip to learn how to sequence
the genomes and antibiotics by blowing
them into tiny pieces and then trying to
put them back together
although these instructors may appear
crazy they are not quite as mad as they
look dr. Pavel PES Nair is a
distinguished professor of computer
science at the University of California
San Diego and a leading authority on
bioinformatics he's dressed this way
because he sometimes thinks that he's a
sheriff of bioinformatics a frontier
discipline underpinning the digital
revolution in biology and personalized
medicine dr. Phillip Campo is an
assistant professor of computer science
at Carnegie Mellon University to learn
why he is dressed this way you'll need
to take this course or read the textbook
bioinformatics algorithms and active
learning approach co-authored by the two
speakers